Help the algorithms help you.
When on YouTube or Instagram, it's really easy to tell these platforms...
...to stop showing you stuff that you don't want to see,...
...stuff that maybe distracts you or that, you know, you don't care about.
I started by blocking sensationalized news, drama, that kind of thing.
I just didn't need it in my life.
Even before doing this, it might be a good idea to clear your history,...
...especially on platforms like YouTube,...
...as a way to kind of attack things at the source and break the cycle.
Limit the appeal of social media.
I absolutely hate the feeling of having spent far too much time scrolling, right?
And I think I'm not the only person that has gone through this.
I've successfully curbed my social media usage in two ways:
First of all, turn off or limit notifications, and I totally get the irony in that.
I know I've promoted turning on notifications on this channel...
...at the end of some of my videos,...
...so if you've done that and decided to turn them back off,...
...I do not blame you whatsoever.
At the end of the day I do not want to have a detrimental impact on your life. Okay?